Or maybe I think briefly of making one of those quinoa breakfast bowls that are so hip right now
but my lazy temperament or my belief that I'm running late
pushes me to choose the 90 minutes in the microwave option.
[off camera, "wow" and laughter]
[laughs] and fire explosion!
[intro theme plays]
But when you think about it, the issue of who is who
isn't really that much more clear cut in real life.
Who is who
Ha, [off camera "Ha"]
Ha
So then there's contemporary Australian moral philosopher
[Deeper voice] moral philosopher
Life was that that ep- hmm, mmm, nah
[Monotone] I am my own lies.
Certain points, to make the chain mail
[Laughter off camera]
I don't- I don't understand what this means
Well, he'd still me by, he'd still me brabrabra
Not only that, you might say Batman is the very essence of Batman [laughs]
[Laughter off camera]
But this principle says that if an-
[Fart noises]
There's a way to say it, but I'm not gonna get there.
[Off camera "I mean-"]
As your osteoblasts are continuously...
[Off camera "And the science people in the audience go Oho"]
[Laughs] Did you say osteoblasts? I'm here, I'm here.
[Laughter]
Oedipus killed a stranger in a fit of rage who turned out to be the-
something.
To get up off the co-uch, co-uch
After Bruce Wayne was reported dea-du-de-du-de
So if you look at the bundle that is me now
compared with the bundle my mom and dad brought home from the hospital
they'd be [incoherent sounds]
[Off camera "right"]
That was a whole- a whole new problem
I feel like I've never had that particular problem before.
[Laughter]
[Incoherent sounds]
It says that personal identity persists over time because you remain in the same body from birth to death.
Birthhh to d-death
[Fart sound]
Vrrr
It would mean that fully rational, healthy, functioning, adult humans might not have personhood
just because no one happens to care about them.
Except for themselves...
[Off camera "but if you're not a person, can you declare personhood on someone?"]
Ohh-hoh then no one is a person.
If you start with no one being people then no one gets to be people.
But others are convinced that there are some parts of the human experience
that simply can't be boiled down to brains.
Don't boil brains.
To speak english rather than b- rather than bublublebleh
These five factors are known as the cognitive criteria [burps]
[Burps]
[Burps]]
Think about- [burps]
Two different kinds of stuff [burps]
Do that again.
But political libertarians are all about freedom from government informa- information
Don't tell me information, government!
And next time, we're gonna think about these issues some more with some helps from one of my favorites kinds of potential persons.
[Sigh]
Lemonade make me salivate.
[Slurping noises]
[Laughter]
Probably got that one on camera.
[Off camera "Yeah!"]
If you value quality of life, then you don't think there's something inherently valubub- valublout
Nor are humans in persistent vede- vedededede
And the sa-me
aww-waaww
[Fart noise]
So a 26 week old fetus would have less personhood than a 34 week old fetus,
which would have less personhood than a new born baby, [silly voice] which would have less personhood than a toddler
Print!
Then the fact is, there is no box- nope, that's not what it says.
[Fart noise]
Hard d-d-deter, hard, hard determinism
[Garbled] hard determinism
Hard d-d-determ
Hard d-
[Laughter]
Don't put that in the outtakes, I'm too embarrassed.
Epicurus argued that nonexistence is not only stupid, but it gets the-
[Muffled laughter off camera]
That's not what it says.
[Laughter off camera]
I said that wrong.
[Laughter]
Nonexistence is stupid! Let's not do it.
[Off camera "It's really stupid to not exist"]
[Laughter]
[Off camera "What are you doing?"]
Stop not existing!
[Laughter]